you've been walking for days your body
aches you're dripping with sweat from
the heat of the sun bearing down
overhead and yet you're wrapped up in
layers upon layers of clothing even your
face is covered and you're wearing thick
black goggles so that not a single
centimeter of your body is exposed your
journey has been long and you feel like
you might die from exhaustion or from
overheating due to these multiple layers
of clothes but dying is better than
being exposed you saw it happen when
your entire team
changed the light cannot be trusted not
even for a fraction of a second it's
been like this for years you've learned
and survived through painful experience
many of those you used to know cannot
say the same you've been alone for so
long you might have given up all hope if
it wasn't for the distress signal coming
from a nearby scp foundation containment
facility site 46. any kind of survivors
would be better than nothing no matter
what kind of sorry shape they were in as
long as they were still human you find
your way to an opening in the side of a
mountain and slide into the cave hoping
you weren't spotted the whole world is
crawling with those things now you can't
let yourself be seen as you trudge down
the cave towards the entrance you see
what looks like a huge black snail trail
splattered on the ground leading into
the facility you try to avoid it and
press on you don't even need a key card
to enter the door has been left ajar the
facility reeks of those things but you
can't see any of them you just hope
they've moved on and left some human
survivors in their wake the place looks
abandoned every step you take echoes
through the empty halls when you find
that the elevator's out you take the
stairs all the way down to level b5
ketter containment lucky for you it
seems all the cells are empty now the
horrors that were kept inside of them
have all long since flown the coop you
keep following that slimy black trail
until you find an abandoned office there
are no people here anymore just a broken
barricade some empty medicine bottles
and a bucket that the people inside the
office had apparently been using as a
toilet you breathe a sigh of
disappointment at finding no one alive
here but you're at least relieved to be
out of the sun you can finally remove
your jacket and head wrap with your
uncovered eyes you notice that a nearby
computer terminal is still powered up
you sit down at the desk and turn on the
monitor because of the emergency
procedures put into place in a k-class
scenario like this safeguards no longer
apply you can access all the information
you need up to and including finding out
what actually happened in the dull glow
of a nearby emergency light you see a
dark shape slumping through the halls in
shadow you tense up then exhale as it
slithers off into an adjoining hall
you're safe for now the terminal has
finally loaded and authenticated your
access you're staring at the file for sd
locks proposal for scp-001
when day breaks it's the only name you
can give the apocalypse your world is
currently experiencing this is one of
the only anomalies in the entire history
of the scp foundation to be given the
apollyon containment class meaning
containment is truly impossible
scp-001 is the most dangerous enemy that
the foundation and planet earth has ever
faced it's always been the principle of
the scp foundation to battle in the dark
so that the civilian world can thrive in
the light but now the light has become
the enemy anyone exposed to any amount
of sunlight for even the briefest period
of time is subjected to the effects of
scp-001
and those effects are beyond horrifying
the scp foundation administrator
released an urgent memo telling
foundation personnel to make their way
to site 19 at all costs because they
need all the help they can get those
exposed to scp-001 in the process are no
longer considered human their new
designation is scp-001-a
these new entities are to be avoided at
all costs but in case of emergencies the
administrator says it is permitted to
cut off parts of your transformed
comrades and eat them to avoid
starvation the memo empathically states
that no attempt should be made to kill
them since you won't succeed you'll just
put yourself at risk when the sun
changed and became scp-008
it instantly affected 6.8 billion
innocent people the second the visible
light touched them whether it was from
the sun itself or even reflected off the
moon their bodies liquefied melting like
candle wax into puddles of living
gelatinous slime this effect isn't
isolated to humans either any biological
entity exposed to sunlight immediately
underwent the same irreversible melting
process into scp scp-001-a
and the horror had only just begun
people transformed into
scp-001a will remain shades of their
former intelligence and personality they
may even try to will their new gooey
mass into a shape resembling their
original form however these individuals
will lose their sense of self if they
come into contact with other instances
of scp-001-a
when they come together zero zero one
dash a instances will bond on a
molecular level waiting up into horrific
giant blobs with only one purpose
integrating more matter into their
bodies that's why they have to be
avoided at all costs you continue to
search the computer terminal for answers
perhaps there was some kind of
contingency plan put in place for this
some way to reverse the effects or at
least escape the nightmare earth has
become
instead you find a series of attachments
linked to the scp-001 file
detailing what seems to be the last days
of the people who'd barricaded
themselves in the facility
most prominent among these were
researcher dr logan igata
her wife ari a security officer named
commander anad and a few others dr igata
had locked herself in the office where
she recorded her final messages to the
world
in the first audio log dr egada and her
companions seemed afraid but hopeful
that there may be some way out of this
situation dr egada reported that most of
the workers at the facility were
transformed during the initial event
their melted bodies had fused outside
the facility and now they were trying to
bust their way back in the defenses had
held so far though and they seemed
confident they would hold long enough
for them to figure out a way to escape
this awful situation you open the second
attachment an incident report and
realize things may not have been as
hopeful as dr regatta let on she
reported hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside
again begging for them to come out and
experience the sun with them they wanted
desperately to add to their ever-growing
biomass in order to experiment with what
exactly would happen they sent out one
of their few remaining d-classes wearing
a full protective suit he didn't last
long the huge creature grabbed him with
tentacles made of reconstituted flesh it
began ripping off his protective suit as
he screamed for mercy it was a monster
made of dozens of people and animals he
could never overpower it the second the
sun touched his skin he melted away and
was absorbed by the great mass holding
him in place guns were ineffective
against these
scp-001-a super entities fire would do
no good it seemed that extremely low
temperatures were the only way to slow
the immense blobs down and even then
not permanently there was one ray of
light in the darkness the site director
had a secret tunnel underneath his
office connected to a tram that could
hopefully take them directly to site 19
without risk of scp-001 exposure it was
a good plan and by far the best option
they had available to them but the best
plans often don't work in practice
you open the next attachment on the
terminal this time it's a video feed you
can actually see dr logan igata and she
looks harrowed by what she's experienced
as it turns out while the others
including her wife ari attempted to exit
through the tunnel
something had happened
dr igata heard ari's voice over her
radio but there was something wrong with
it it was too low too guttural and
filled with gurgles
scp-001 had gotten her she was changed
the monster from above had crawled in
through the ceiling it had taken them
all of them and converted them into
something less than human any hope of
escape now seemed gone ari told dr igata
that it would be fine but it was such a
bright beautiful day outside and she was
wasting it locked up inside that office
she tormented dr egatto with shared
memories of their life and love of that
day in the sun where they bound their
lives together the monster with ari's
voice did everything it could to try to
convince her to give up and join them
but she wasn't ready to go just yet you
look away from the screen when you hear
a sound in the corner you see a dark
puddle of some unknown substance and
then some skeletal hands rising out of
it the hands are pulling themselves out
of the puddle followed by a skeletal
face covered in matted hair you have to
stop yourself from screaming until a
flash from a nearby security light makes
the figure disappear it's a normal
puddle once again your mind is playing
tricks on you you open the next
attachment another video and see that dr
igota's condition has deteriorated she
looked pale frantic and thin she was
using a knife to draw her own blood onto
a piece of blood-stained parchment
covered in strange symbols he got a
ranted about her theory what if 001 took
the minds and bodies of its victims but
not their souls through performing some
kind of arcane blood ritual she hoped to
at least rescue and keep the soul of ari
even if her mind and body were lost you
open the next attachment it seemed that
agata's ritual worked but not in the way
she hoped the twisted soul of ari driven
mad by scp-001 had taken over the file
it begins corrupting the text of the
scp-001 file into crazy ranting about
how futile it is to fight it then cuts
to an even more frightening video feed
dr igata in her sleep tossing and
turning in a makeshift bed in the corner
of her office the camera approaches her
in first person and lingers over her
sleeping body an oily skeletal hand
reaches past the camera and runs its
fingers through dr igoda's hair it's
that exact same hand you saw reaching
out of that black puddle earlier you
must have seen ari's lingering spirit
with a lump in your throat you open the
next attachment and watch the video you
see dr igata now truly broken she'd been
haunted by ari's demonic spirit for a
long time now and it has clearly taken
its toll she is waving around a handgun
while she speaks she now believes there
is only one way to escape but not like
this she doesn't want the gun to draw
attention to her body she doesn't want
to become part of that mass even if she
is dead she opens a drawer on her desk
she's recording at and places the gun
inside dr regatta then apologizes to her
loved ones who are likely long since
dead or assimilated and turns off the
recording for the last time in that
moment you realize there's a single
drawer in the desk in front of you when
you reach forward and open it you see
the same handgun dr egada was holding is
laying inside you pick it up and study
it weighing your options perhaps there
truly is no other way out then you see
an update on the file one more
attachment has been added while you were
studying the gun you feel your heart
pounding in your chest as you reach
forward and open the attachment the text
has been changed entirely the file on
scp-001
is now a poem an ode to the sun
and to the love they shared then a video
file spontaneously opens itself on the
screen
it's a video of you shot from behind
you see those oily skeletal hands
reaching for you in the dark
just like they did with dr igata in that
moment you panic and fire them behind
you hoping to scare off the spirit
instead the sound of the gunshots
attracts something far worse the immense
blob of screaming melted flesh charges
towards the office you try to barricade
the door but it is not enough the flesh
seeps and bursts through and grabs you
in its meaty tentacles you scream and
try to escape but it won't save you
nothing will save you the flesh carries
you upstairs out through the empty halls
out into the cave you can see the light
in the distance as the blob buries you
towards it you won't be alone for much
longer in fact you won't be alone ever
again now check out
scp-001 the scarlet king and
scp-001 which is the real 001 for more
deep dives into
scp-001 mysteries and lore